hello everybody welcome to part 12 of
let's play penumbra overture I
accidentally found out what to do while
you weren't watching sorry about that uh
what happened was I was reading it wrong
it wasn't the gas cap on the truck that
was sealed shut it was the gas cap on
the gasoline can so I dragged my little
hammer on to it and his bam bam bam
[ __ ] came right off so getting right
back into it here we go victory oh yeah
oh yeah I'm so great
shut up John only I can come up with the
witty comments key oh shut up Billy you
guys say shut up Paul II really don't
care there's gotta be trusted wrinkled
gift
oh you bring terrible points I did eyes
the shafts beyond this collapsing of the
sky I thought if you look closely so do
I know I don't
a century of days is pasture it I saw
this area last what would even the
disease once sought to kill Paul read
whether I took them on a wild poultry
chase they end in dead sure Luke a
murdered a big metal door but after all
my years I knew the case more hide and
seek turn to seek align and I buried up
here beneath the solid rock sky oh man
have I said how about how bad your plays
on play on words our plays on words I
don't know shut up
nope nope
fu what about here
oh yeah ah right in there ah go oh so
awesome
aw stop go backwards to the magnet
oh yeah I was just getting the ramming
speed wrong yeah [ __ ]
Oh keep going keep going keep going you
think you know given how old this mine
is why would they have a remote-control
excavator it just doesn't make any sense
whatever done man it's gone got all the
way yeah why'd you stop with fu fu oh
right
it seems so strange now to have been
guided like a blind man by a faceless
stranger whose sanity was clearly waning
disposition unknown for all I knew this
Billy didn't even have a disposition it
all right let's look sturdy I trust it
uh off so brave yeah took that like a
champ
alright moving on you got here come on
come on come on ha oh I know that sound
hey you can't fool me
ha ha what do what is that Oh
oh yeah Oh whoa where'd it go
way to go buddy huh there you go way to
go what what oh oh oh my god huh ah what
was that did it fall wow oh wow oh wow
is that a worm oh did I read a note
about it I didn't I didn't I didn't I
didn't have time to write ha ha I
wouldn't expect you to be able right ah
man
oh that was good that was good I haven't
seen like a monster in the attack him at
all
that's good another one bring it on
yeah from the center of the earth I'll
shut up whispers all right got it done
anew what'd you write won't you just
tell me where is it lead it leads to
salvation
normal worms oh this looks like a worm
tunnel Oh more eggs
bring it on ah spider [ __ ] up [ __ ] up ah
[ __ ] ah yeah go yes get get off ah [ __ ]
you hate you oh [ __ ] I'm running [ __ ] it
[ __ ] it I can't take this good [ __ ]
hi sponge getting the best of me ah ha
ha Pinker I don't have iPad painkiller
yeah yeah fast for you you have to pass
through Oh No ah I got a chair back off
oh yeah that gotcha here have another
taste on my chair boom ah
oh come on Rick ah well how'd you get
behind it BAM and then the finishing
blow
one more finishing blow oh yeah that's
right oh you like that bonk
[ __ ] off ooh something in there no
boring
you did spider Oh switch kerplunk
kerplunk
uh what ah why did I do that why did I
do that
oh why did I do that it's so gonna call
every monster in the area to be oh nope
nope nope nope no no no way I mocked by
dart Terry
Oh blocks away knocked away I can't get
through this barrel back off got chair I
am invincible with my chair
ah yeah don't even try it
ah don't even try it I'm too great
awesome muscular everything you are not
come on come on bring it bring it on oh
yeah I'll finish you off at the barrel
oh yeah I'm so tough oh yeah now you're
dead [ __ ] off bring it on
oh yeah you too yeah all here
I'll squish one more ah go do it BAM
yeah BAM oh yeah well yeah you did you
did oh you want some
BAM ah I get I going oh yeah haha and
I'll finish you
ah oh you tried you didn't get there oh
why does this pickaxe hurt less than a
chair huh huh sure you're my best weapon
best weapon ah MS chair Allah you felony
come on yeah ah [ __ ] you but I dodged it
I'm so pro all here now you're done I
know no you're not done
get get ah [ __ ] mad imma die to a
spider you're all gonna watch me die to
a spider oh [ __ ] this what I'm what else
am I supposed to do I can't run anywhere
Oh finally you're dead [ __ ] why did I
hit that alarm all in such pain look at
me Oh can't feel my arms and legs and
how am i picking this up
it's just John's a pansy and I'm making
up for it leave me I'm sushi
what am i I do oh my god ooh I'm not
banning this chair sure mine Cheers mine
dude take it away from me Oh was there
anything else in this room I forget
anything why did I do that
oh why did I do that
oh they lead into the wall dumbass okay
just some old sacks and there was
nothing in here man oh I'm gonna die I'm
gonna die it's gonna happen
I got no health bar it's a laudanum why
did they have better health to stuff
back in like the 1700s and now whatever
whatever
oh hello push a rock down okay I push
the alarm I didn't do jack oh I know I
know I know it's a time thing oh I fight
I just run around the spider oh that's
why they had the second cavern right
here so I could run around them ah
Marquess Oh stupid stupid all right
whatever I was just doing that to let
you guys laugh at me cuz it's funnier
that way okay uh yeah come on do
something yep okay open run run run run
run run run run run run run ah that's
why there are all those secondary
caverns and all day ah so stupid um oh
now I'm oh now oh yeah it's open I'm on
my way to victory oh no no tell it yeah
yeah oh I'm so good oh yeah oh look at
me you can't see right now but I'm
flexing my muscles oh yeah oh shut up
Billy the ground I hear your trembling
Tootsie's because old rebel offensive
my Tootsie's ain't trundling things come
to those that wait when they want them
or not yeah yeah and soon I think you're
awake we'll be old I'll [ __ ] you red
I mean Billy units are graduated or in
reality is calling just as the Reaper
beckons me what the metal door finally
greeting I only hope I need gun ring to
me no man I hope you do
oh this looks like worm central what's
this cages can't jump up on up there
goes my plan ah worm worm Glenelg worm
okay what we got here I am here
section C tool storage Charlie should go
there first shaft 12 refinery chef 13
oh so many shafts all over the place
oh-ho-ho-ho okay yeah right yep this
looks good promising open Oh monsters in
here I didn't think so
back off Oh oh yeah yeah whatever
Oh punch through with my fists ooh
that's ornate oh come here
get over there nothing whole bunch of
nothing
okay all right go go go up up do late I
have to pause here thanks so much for
watching and stick around because part
13 will be right on the way thanks for
watching bye bye